when I used to do before every practice
I put on I got every fight that you've
ever fought like not I'm not missing one
so I put the DVD on and I would watch
the DVD right six and a month
that made me on the treadmill it made me
keep running and I was like you know I
never really thought about it because I
was interested in this fight then they
had the interviews and a buildup who's
talking [ __ ] and I was like man boxing
here Mike - I'm Evan Britton and we have
a special guest here today
great dressed man former champion
sensational fighter soon to fight back
for the championship Tyron Woodley I'm
bummed we out here you know what is
usually the first native people he got
that right you caught me Tyrone so yeah
everything was right I appreciate you
guys having me the warm welcome
hell yeah brother you don't the happy
but I am away but I you know I've had
better days but you know it's a part of
being a champion I had one Dave - yeah
that's right god bless you are what you
something no just the thing right no
this just gives you opportunity to make
a big comeback you know if all it does
is gives you more opportunities to do
things when you think things that happen
and they're bad and they could never be
erased and stuff you know you get a
chance to do what you want in life and
reef that and clean yourself up you know
yeah I like that that's a good mindset
because you think about you know we look
at what's in front of us and sometimes
it's a loss or a lesson and but we don't
look at the things that around it well
you know what let me take him brother
please when I was a little kid no one I
used to be like 1439 to read about the
over good in a fight but the ones that
interested me the most was the guys that
got beat in the first fight they ever
had a third fight that head got knocked
out cold and milli ated and they came
back training and I kept coming back
yeah I kept coming back and kept winning
and captain when a man lost another
fight we kept what never gave up yeah
never became discouraged and then one
they they got a chance to fight boom
knock the champion out another champion
boom imagine they really gave up and got
discouraged when they got what he lost
even got knocked out and then once they
became champion they came champion for
long runs broke their history books and
record books and stuff but they never
gave up not easier to give up being
knocked out humiliated in front of
people but they step to it those guys I
really admired back then because they
showed that you don't have to be perfect
you could have flaws and still do
sensational things that nobody else
could you know duplicate that's Christ
you know you know it's funny is that
they kind of remind me of my story when
I got the title I thought I was tending
though undefeated whooping everybody
adds knocking people out submitting
people then you know I felt from my
world title for the first time and I was
undefeated I just didn't think I could
lose at that point time nobody can
convince me that nobody anyone can beat
me at the moment so I went out there and
the first time I sons had ever watched
me fight so they came to the fight for
the first time I wanted my whole family
there
I had a manta ray d in my gym for the
belt when I brought it back home and I
just thought the reasons why I was
fighting for there was no way I can lose
fight for my family for my city st.
Louis I go out there and I get knocked
not just out knock the [ __ ] out badly
like I look at it I can't immediately
imagine as me on my daddy knocked I do
it the [ __ ] out so I'm looking at it
almost from a fan standpoint versus -
you get knocked out but it was the
biggest fall in the Showtime and kids
with Darian's for all the marbles
but after that I just came back next
Friday not to do out in 36 seconds then
I just kept getting that momentum and
there were some losses and some lessons
but then I finally got the chance to she
was talking about and I was fighting
Robbie Lawler which you guys knows a
beast he's gonna go down in the Hall of
big-time big-time be big but he was a
friend of mine a teammate of mine and I
followed him and out of all the fighters
he's probably my top three is just being
a fan of them so now I got to fight this
guy this vicious dangerous Robbie Lawler
fight out of here two times in a row and
fight in front yeah cray fighting fights
right fighting for you know I'm good
good but damn my man's like hey you got
a fight on my session we got to do it
then I mean we boys we fighting on the
same team
but I may never get this opportunity
again so I went into the fight nobody
really gave me a chance I've been out
for 18 months they thought that you know
be rusty and I said man I look at my
coach he was like you know if you need
more water bottles I say you don't need
more than one water bottle you know
legal being it out tonight and I just
saw it in his eyes when I looked at him
day he wasn't ready for that kind of
fight I just saw a your rice like I my
life depended on it
god that's amazing good well you're also
a high school football player yeah
Mizzou Tigers yeah how's that what's the
chant with Mizzou mi z zo you for mi z
[ __ ] can't you if we yeah yeah yeah
I lived on that Street yeah Sophie
laughs oh honey a documentary so in
first in like that's my actual street
like I didn't live like in a surrounding
area like well I walked to that quick
trip that was right in you know my
barbershop was you know my barbershop
was right next to the Walgreens I went
on fire and the guys was coming over to
the set the auto shop next door they
said no you're not gonna set that on
fire I said no because if you set that
on fire it's gonna catch the barbershop
and if you shut this barbershop you got
smoke over so guys is outside with guns
no that's what happened when at the
black of 77 in New York if people are
fired this dude with the machine gun
they say we ain't learning this one down
long as we're outside - good -
everything here now if I would the gun
really riots - yeah they were no they
the people at the stores yeah and I was
shooting a movie straight out of kind of
thunder and like there before of the kid
living you gonna funny thing like it's
like the apocalypse Mel why don't what
whatever I was going on first is it's
crazy because I was doing a movie
Straight Outta Compton filming the riot
scenes in the movie as a real ride
what's going on your Ferguson so it's
just it's nuts out of thema for a circle
world talk a little bit about how you
came to fighting them yeah you know to
be honest I've been fighting my whole
life gang banging fighting siblings in
the house me and my friends used to
fight for fun industry and it just
became a part of like my lifestyle like
I wasn't always the biggest guy
my mentor thought that help to help with
experience in fighting in the ring I
don't know I think it's crazy but my
street fights gave me an advantage and a
guy that didn't have a lot of street
fight he saw that was part of my amateur
experience just having the experience
facing that fear of fighting another
person was you think I think so yeah now
that I look at the aspect of it you know
fighting in the friend industry don't
know that cutting it's just that fear
instead of that fear of your unexpected
but you think about this guy the worst
he could do is knock me out yeah and
he's gonna be my friend after this
because I was asked me a similar
question I'm like when I say I don't
like fighting yeah I take it the wrong
way I love winning I love competing I
love challenging myself but I've been
fighting my whole life I fought in the
house for the last slice of pizza and I
fought in the street he fought I fought
over colors I fought because I was 100
pounds in in little school and people
thought out you want to step up to me
you're gonna get [ __ ] up so I fought
so much that it doesn't scare me
the thought of fighting somebody in the
Octagon with rules and I can grab him
and slow like anything is nothing really
bothers me like nothing can happen are
knocked out there I live to see another
day and you're not routine brothers and
sisters right deep Oh imagine what kind
of fear that is when your brother
brother bullies on you man I wasn't even
a fighter come home you had to wait to
your mother come home to come to the off
wow yeah you got way to your marketing
bully you know but you got way to your
mother come on get on with my clothes I
still spray some Cologne on it closely
the beat mom it was worth to sometimes
though you had the juice will use pity
right so kind of work there sometime I
got a story for you Mike Joe I know
you've been waiting on it alright so so
I as I was coming up a fighting that I
was washing the way the Mike's bill
right he's looked shorted in a lot of
the heavyweights so he had the users
head motion to cut in to get closer to
guys
I may miss or question off his punch
anything goes right so I might share
five eight I'm fighting it 170 pounds
most guys are six foot two super long
but I got a lot of arms so I can fight
the long fight but I can use this same
kind of motion to [ __ ] cut in and
getting close to her people it's good so
so I watch them and I hate running like
when I say hey I hate running but what I
used to do before every practice I put
all I got every fight that you've ever
fought like not I'm not missile right so
I put the DVD on and I would watch the
DVD and run 6:00 in the morning that
made me stay on the treadmill really
made me so sure but made me keep running
and I was like you know I never really
thought about it because I was
interested in this fight and then they
had the interviews and the build-up and
he was talking [ __ ] and I was just like
man just do it onto a [ __ ] he's trying
to [ __ ] you up so that's kind of how I
think when I fight so you were coming to
st. Louis to do your show right yeah I
hit Dana up I said Dan I'll actually for
[ __ ] ever I said but Mike Tyson is
coming to st. Louis and goddammit I
gotta meet him 100% so he said I got it
done so he set it up HR people they hit
me up you probably remember this so it
was in st. Louis right and I had his
people are like you know this is my city
I got everything a lot anything Mike
need let me know
I restaurants I got anything because I
got I guess st. Louis in the bag so yeah
you know he need his arm he Mike needs
his medicine said [ __ ] I call my doctor
right now I'm here throwing the script
for anything so let me know that it out
so he said all right cool so he said he
nice our diesel so I'm I don't smoke at
this time oh no what the [ __ ] sighs oh
no what the [ __ ] he was and I saw I'm
like him I say is this a code name for
so I'm asking my people and I'm like so
I'm about to call my [ __ ] doctor to
see if he can throw in the script for
this I start grabbing so I saw I think
ask my guy and he's like that's we I
said oh [ __ ] I said no my god
right here hey my god am i do that's
coming in town that I wanted me if I
don't come through with my [ __ ] sound
easy man so now I'm like oh [ __ ] I don't
know where to get this yellow smoke am i
back in the street again do I really
gotta go out and score nickel bag in the
streets of Ferguson so I'm freaking out
about this Mike I promise you people
from my church bishops all shocked
engage I didn't even know you smoke
everywhere I was trying to make sure I
had the weed so I can meet Mike I seen
him not be looking at me like you
[ __ ] drop the ball on the weed so I
met him it was dope he had his package
and that was a funny a Stefan only what
we used to do is go anything
we need to have them contact I was
freaking out cuz I'm like I'm like do I
want to do this but how can I come out
without it and then I was just like
literally going back if I had a moral
war back it takes a village to get much
as weed in Missouri I've it's awesome
man are you into cannabis what's your
relationship with it you know what my
homie had cancer you know any clay bathe
no I don't know what's clay baked clay
be the family out there I don't know it
just crazy so crazy boxing community
does minx and everybody there from yeah
yeah yeah so what my buddy had cancer
and he was fighting cancer with cannabis
oil mm-hmm and then I've had so many
surgeries you know broke my hand in a
fight punch somebody heads for my labor
Marchand uppercut problem our foot
trying to kick someone in the head so I
had all these injuries and I'm getting
older so I had to [ __ ] start healing
so I started using the CBD to heal the
gummies I gotta make that with this
company it's coming to CBD MD and they
started sending me [ __ ] like that me
shake from the work so I never had a bad
stigma of smoking weed because I never
heard like somebody smoked weed and they
just tried and when shot a whole school
up like that's your crack or something
so I never had a negative effect but
I've seen so many beneficial effects
with whether you got anxiety you go
through depression you stressed out you
know you gotta hate any kind of reason
so you know I just I just support
anything that's gonna be scientific and
if you take a damn ass when you're
taking the drug so yeah that's kind of
my stance on it awesome in a minute let
me see I'm powerful to join it'll be a
big fat one fatty it's gonna be
ridiculous yes I'm a [ __ ]
smoker but I'm a roll one come on out so
why can't you smoke I got a fight yeah I
gotcha I gotcha I mean it might be worth
it I heard this so there's like some
rest potion is worth later blood is
worth two years out no no no not that
two months though I tell us what is the
Paul I'm so confused on the policy do we
policy yeah with them because it seems
like part of the time you guys can use
it well this is this is what happens I
understand you cannot have marijuana
within your system within fight week so
that is between Tuesday and actually
Sunday so when you get there on Tuesday
from that day all the way into Sunday
now it depends on how much fat sales you
got how hard you work out how much you
sweat yeah your body on how long it's
going to be in your system so some guys
are trying to test the math and they
[ __ ] up and it was any assistant
during that week so what you have to do
is make sure that if it's eight weeks
for you or ten weeks or six weeks
whatever time and they've got to be out
of your system by that week of the fight
and usually know when you're gonna fight
proximately like twelve week solid take
like five weeks again to Train I've
gotten it out in 21 days yeah but I mean
you don't want to paint know about
missing like I was stressing yeah you
don't you're gonna be missing a fight
and misses us millions because you won't
join they join go meter afterwards
absolutely absolutely man I do not
record that you're just jumping around
roll hell yeah smoke me say I'm nervous
cuz I just promised I was gonna be a fat
joy now I'm at the mercy of I'm one for
work dude there's a praise you don't owe
you brother
oh no I took I saw this on YouTube and I
hit mommy burnin up on my dog I need
that and I want that they didn't have it
and then they said oh we only had a
display model we can't sell the house it
give me one second
so I hate burnout so y'all need a dog
alright so this is for the people that
are not the road what's this
I can't with the strength riding this is
this is a joint I know what you think
you like [ __ ] a roller catch a vibe baby
it ain't gonna really roll a joint the
right way so watch this I'm not like it
some kind of saddened lovely Metiria
right here right so now you take three
flower right quick sure you drop it in
there now I'm just a roller guys by the
way
I'll you'll see you're a ringer dude
professional roller for right now you're
the ringer man I don't know this doesn't
look like his first time no you know it
did it didn't look like he was gonna
actually work the first it looks like a
lot of work huh no but wait till you see
the results on you got to put in a lot
of work for the results right I agree we
just have this guy named Daniel here
yeah you don't know who you are and you
know she's supposed to do I'm their
chief rolling officer alright some rich
this is amazing and smash down you've
got all this cookies stuff yes if
cookies just don't brand but it's just
cool if you just make cool [ __ ] and I
said [ __ ] it my homie I got a represent
that's cool no this is what's tricky for
homes in it good I have [ __ ] this up
once
oh no praise not today hi so you let the
top of the joint right this neither
turnout wait huh
also draw is gonna be [ __ ] amazing oh
no I may be a [ __ ] God when I leave
it oh no all these people were [ __ ]
regular see that positions you playing
football running back way
whoa look at that that's some [ __ ]
right whoa magic it was like mist I to
write my is magical hey that was a
[ __ ] magic trick that would've [ __ ]
up just would have been nice gosh I got
the weed on my mother deadly back it's
the end of it it's poor not easy in yeah
that now you could have added to look
look we're normally we do it I didn't
want to show off yeah wish you did sure
ha ha let's do this hell man
that's what do you have any do you have
any like businesses you got going
outside everything I do is awesome oh my
god
you know I do anything that's art or
entertainment acting stunts television
broadcasts movies TV I produce a podcast
podcast Lorna will show up these nuts
you were in straight out of college
right so I do that start doing music
recently stand-up comedy that was crazy
that big fish came on the set yeah she
came on the set and actually mom I'm
homies were bone and bone is like the
one that got ran over first time dude he
died no he didn't die the second guy
passed but but he came on set and it was
like are we gonna make a truce that ah
but in reality I think he was coming
because some parts of the movie then I
was incriminating on him and he didn't
like it and he want to try to come to
flex oh yeah yeah I'm not the biggest
shirt fan yeah because of that like if
you that shows yeah no [ __ ] very well
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the guy everybody says he
being that the guy he now claims me yeah
mine in the girl a with a nice guy you
know he came to my house at one time in
Connecticut for a party my birthday
party that's cool you know I've been
around those guys writing in there a
little while when they had that yeah
calling in the Devereaux yeah that was
those yeah that was a little crazy
though yeah you know I think he crazy
people around you know I'm sure he
didn't anybody everybody's do what they
do you know how many [ __ ] I mean having
Dre has they're damn sure I'm sure
Dre don't agree with the [ __ ] he did and
vice versa P you know Jimmy handing this
off Heisman through the man brother how
many I can say that yeah cetera and
wrote a joint for our myosin and passes
what I think about that by the way
Straight Outta Compton they came up and
she that's what incredible huh so Mason
you know the thing about the movie is
the scenes that I didn't even
participate in I saw for the first time
on film as well when I sat down and
watched it it was like I didn't expect
when easy you died to make you kind of
emotional almost more I love it it was
from season of where they were kind of
funny I suspected to be a lot of ripe
amount of music which would have been
enough but the story I mean Gary did his
thing on that it was so better people
drain those guys you know some of those
young like Jason makes you to play
eazy-e and O'Shea
those were they first movies they did a
couple small films but actual feature
fans are the first one is such a
important role for them I have no idea
what this you did the people like with
Eminem host why you know just tugging it
out I had no idea you doing that paper
[ __ ] well go do that [ __ ] to you do you
don't think you know human beings do
that other human beings but they grew up
in from the neighborhood
people have been way more violent than
that in the history of human being I
know [ __ ] [ __ ] go to Mexico she was
going on right now
like you've talked about Mike I mean
we're it's it's a miracle that we've had
so much peace in this time yeah we're in
the great peace
I think he's gonna leave yeah I love
foot to be because of that yeah that's
definitely one reason have you
experienced any of these psychedelic
molecules judging based on the
literature that you use to describe this
format I'm probably have not boy
mushrooms around ayahuasca you're pretty
you're just clean straight black drugs
[Laughter]
from the Himalayan mountain no now we'll
take that any interest yeah yeah my life
is a trip I need to take another one do
you ever go and hang out with those on
it guys in Austin yeah that I did um I
did a video there about social media
hate and we just don't work out so those
guys
they might be interested you know
they're all well they look like they
know for sure no they are you talked
about no I said it I didn't everything
is naturally plant-based organic
supplements and all you sign up roof
you're just doesn't yeah you're clear
psyche drug psychedelic drug for love
them especially the total if I'm at the
mind-expanding
yeah poof no make you feel educated lazy
and everything it's like inner inner
knowledge you gain insight and you just
don't mispronounce any words your
grammars [ __ ] on point and then you
become a beast in the sheets beyond
measure another you can't miss you can't
miss in that department so you're
describing it well but I'm just you know
from what I hear what I hear
it's awesome them like how does it make
you feel when you got young greats like
this guy here telling you what an
inspiration you were to them hey um I'll
not feel them and why hey on one
occasion I feel really um I'm feel
really on it you know I mean he would
acknowledge that and say something like
that and then another kid I found I
think I feel it well enough example
stuff you gotta be a real example I
think the thing that people don't
recognize is if somebody was so perfect
you couldn't relate to me because you
said everything is so [ __ ] happy but
if somebody I feel like he's been
through something and I went through
this and now I made me to this and I
bumped again I think that's more
realistic so myself I tell people if
you're looking at me to me to be perfect
don't base your life don't base your
kids don't look at me for that if you
want somebody that's gonna be real a
genuine heart trying to do right by
people that might [ __ ] up here there but
he'll make right of it then then you can
follow me because those are people that
actually influence for real I didn't
know about the pinna when I was young
his age and I was starting stories they
have a lot of endorsements of the first
guy before you and I had all the
endorsement and I started living life
and I [ __ ] my endorsements and I fell
in love and I stood and fell apart and
worldwide in front of everybody but they
wasn't endorsing you they were an
awesome the brand they wanted to see
yeah yeah
people now word or shoe you would never
lose endorse me they want more of that
every time yeah but you know forget
about this losing everything you know if
we get that feeling you know I mean wow
[ __ ] how I was looking at so you're on
top of the world man I was looking to
top um what the [ __ ] happens I was I was
I was reading something on your history
in your career and during that period of
time I was like this to had a bill for
$10,000 a week in towels the [ __ ]
that's crazy with the we a beast god
crazy dude
something that's happened recently one
is everything but it was too much I
can't handle it I thought I could too
much stuff how are you twenty one twenty
two twenty the [ __ ] could have
for the beach they change boxing for
sure literally on the top of the world
man
but this stage of my life I feel on top
of the world it's awesome you know it's
funny I've always want to ask you this
question like some people look at like
I'm like old school I'm young yeah but I
think old school and a lot of our
fighters they got Instagram and all
these ways of watch fighting so they
want is just okay he did this punch jump
out the cage and did the Superman [ __ ]
let me do it
they don't want to Chile Joey Joey Joey
Joey but when I watched you fight it's a
machine that's been drilled so many
times that even if you didn't want to
slip that punch and kind of left you
don't do it anything yes and think I
will pay big time waiting to see some of
them drills and watch them just like
I've seen the fights but the drills that
make em on YouTube to show them all the
drill one winner I'm like is something
else man stop you know let me tell you
something about YouTube YouTube is um
YouTube is so happy with time too if one
of us dial you to have a effort yeah
well I could watch you forever my great
great grandkids could watch you your
great-great grand grandkids it'll be
able to see you you can't see your great
great grandparents but your great great
grandkids will be able to see you I will
show you our picture they get you TARDIS
[ __ ] oh yeah guys don't even thinking
about nug entire who's this - my old
trainer when I was a teenager 1314 well
Kevin Rooney tomorrow was the teacher
Mike but how long did you do these
drills just this particular so your legs
are part of your low back well let's
know you keep doing round after round
after round and by the time you finish
on your drill you'll be an hour looking
down with the weaving drills you know me
being a shadow boxing goes
when you're [ __ ] it into those Forte
I'm 14 years I watched you weigh my
sword is 15 to 35 to build like the
function you want to stop boxing lose my
bet you picture Joe loose on my bed
looks so awesome as a trip I was a fat
guy happy to the joel over my pet series
of four impressive victories out of the
gym I mean you just went all out and
practice cus D'Amato brought let's say
you have no caste or even know if I'm
from New York I was just a big kid he's
a mug people as a kid I got sent away
and if I met cousin from what you know
choosing our detention center crazy
[Music]
the introduced many cuz I was locked up
updated the staff how do you feel about
Teddy these days man oh no I love teddy
yeah yeah she's doing a lot of
broadcaster right yeah everyone's down
that would be Who I am basically you
know I don't get angry
yeah you can't but it won't change yeah
yeah I find this picture real quick
there's a picture someone's a fan mate
and I was hitting somebody and I was
like trying to weave you know you
punching you weave it to saying yeah
sorry shut up so I try to punch and
weave at the same time and they captured
a shot my goddamn wife I'm gonna make me
look dumb all right like no the Wi-Fi is
really bad here terrible well it's got
more calories to believe in moving after
you punch somebody come right back boom
boom
tough guy come right back there's the
pool we hit me they can rape it pow pow
yeah but it's a picture that he compared
to his arm there's a picture of me
weaving and smoking some I would have
shot and then it was Mike we're gonna
smoke some I overshot it's dope
holy moly yeah this yeah look at that
dude it's awesome
did you play punch-out as a kid not a
[ __ ] all day dude they're trying to
bring it back without Mike yeah the big
Knicks think of it as yeah there's a big
stink over man people are pissed off cuz
they're like young guys built that okay
it was built on Mike Tyson man to the do
our own game yeah shame on you Nintendo
shame on I'm sure you will be Joe ass
okay pretty people were pissed off man
what do you do for fun Mike I come here
I work every day I [ __ ] with the kids in
the family and we make deals and
eventually we hear from friends is how
things are doing people dying she's
happening in the world then inspect box
changes has your life for so long no
listen right the business of Bachmann is
just not who I am you know the business
of boxing I gotta get her to [ __ ] my
[ __ ] I'm kind of gotta be I fall in
love with the fighter they need money
they calling me and [ __ ] out give him
the money so I'll be horrible in that
business you know any of them look I
will use now excuse me you need to look
out what you know I ain't that kind of
guy you know I mean when I'm down and
I'm very grateful that when I'm down I'm
only down because I'm done because I
want to be done I don't want to do
nothing with my life I think I always
have always had friends and our friends
always looked out for me in there I have
all these friends and they were very
always kind to me I was really never
down it was always down here
you know never really physically that
much down with him financial help or
just I was so self-destructive up here I
wanted to die I thought I was the bad
guy I should have been dead as some
I'm not worthy of anything that none of
us worthy God said we are like filthy
rags but he made it all covered us with
blood you're my mom told me she said you
know I don't care if you in the middle
having sex you still the righteousness
of God like you're not righteous because
of who you are you're righteous because
God is righteous
hey no cuz we too hard on ourselves I
was away for a while I'm like [ __ ] I met
I'm doing great in this category I'm
doing great at parenting I'm sucking at
relationships you know I mean I'm
sucking at organization but you know
sometimes you know we have to submit you
know we know we're badass and we have to
submit with watching them form around us
but we can learn from it ya know that's
a good point yes Wesley I listen me and
my wife when we dated we never had a
fight once we got married we were like
animals the first year we really didn't
know but we knew each other for years
well data for years lived with each
other we thought we knew each other we
got married it with hell we had to learn
to redirect our respect you know yeah
man I think everybody every real
relationship goes through that yeah you
know you have a family see ya kid five
kids well who told us I got a 15 yo song
you have a 16 year old often that's hard
it's hard to keep up cuz you can't be
you can't go over the edge where you to
old where you got on the new you know
the white New Balance with the blue blue
inside and they curled up you can't go
all the way there but you can't do the
skinny jeans and started trying to do
these new dances with you got to find
somewhere where you still can be the
cool dad yeah that's a worse spot that's
what I'm doing you know I deal with that
now because I'm the kind of dad well I'm
the kind of guy good discipline never
you have to suffer and sacrifice to get
with your when I'm like 25 push-ups for
every meal you ain't [ __ ] I realize like
me my son was talking and um people from
this generation what do we call them
again already old Lenny of the stuff
what quit what's great to them is wasn't
great to us right we were more
luckily great to them who we did more
physically work to accomplish great
things whatever they say been around
these guys do a computer live stuff then
I when we came to a meeting with
physically shape 100% you're ready to
come to work and they don't have to be
that with it you know you know how I get
the credit I do [ __ ] like this
I go live boom my kid my kid see me live
I wouldn't share my time sir hey I'm the
coolest dad on the block
ain't nobody cooler than me right now
it's got my holders over here so if you
do that then that's your way else to
bridge the gap yeah for sure it's my
back pocket
well I got a rental car where were you
born I was in 82 but old school I
remember this both a lady too so though
43 ever 16 they do this thing 1660 the
eighties baby are her ladies man well
you were you are 87 87 87 like a ball
today I'm ordering to you I remember
yesterday 31 31 yeah man it's an
interesting thing that generate
generational differences yeah you know
like even from the generation before you
Mike like those guys were world war two
badass bad [ __ ] bad and what do
you think about the generation right
before you like we're getting wise
compare your generation say that the
work that the generation before me is
what our latest generation in the
sixties right monsters dear giants at
that time guys are some guy the fact
facing their life at that time in the
streets yeah the [ __ ] riots in the
streets people can murder Martin Luther
King derived from back paths you know
strong figures getting murdered for no
real
anarchy going on yeah I look at I look
at my generation and I think that before
me was like the industrialist period and
work to ask our factory workers
everything was hard-earned and in my
generation had a little bit of that but
they also had a little bit
television oh yeah ate better then
better trainer as it has done to
condition theirs were a little softer
because their parents had been so hard
though you're peddling your Panther or
in your faith yeah yo and if have in
your faith parent yeah yeah that's right
but I've seen that generation where we
have more knowledge of like how to train
and put in science behind it and then
they dumped over to all these entitled
I'm supposed to Guinea just because
because I quit my job full-time and
started fighting and training every day
I deserve for you to [ __ ] kiss my ass
yeah Parliament that there's people that
are doing it yeah I know but they fall
in love with the fight for money they
fall in love with the football player
yeah no they actually get a personal
interest in the person yes many other
early like you ain't neva dish yet so
why do you think you can just be like um
I'm just the greatest coming to earth
and all the ways you want me and my dude
it's like man everything in life is
about how much you put into it how much
you work you're willing to work and give
you know I mean that's the only thing I
don't think I've ever been I've heard
those stories about people getting super
lucky and just being like given winning
the lottery
just somebody comes to you and for
whatever thing you've created they say
man I want to pay you a million dollars
for that idea look up the curse of the
lottery winners oh [ __ ] but for me in my
life nothing has been about how [ __ ]
hard I never had the money before and
they just not getting a big hit under
for knows to do with it Magne gotta be
the [ __ ] been a wolf ever since
I exist and all sudden I got time I'm
poppy anybody warlock I never had
anybody say I like meth little girl told
me I'm looking nice I will man and then
you won't even consider the tax element
of it I don't blow you blow really don't
have to have left the cursus win any
lottery one big and lost big they had to
divorce bankruptcy even death
theft yeah it's crazy I mean I'd be
scared to go that number off
they can't help it publicly they gotta
be showing this yeah it's not [ __ ]
people start wearing masks now though
it's almost interesting like it's a
conspiracy be careful what you wish for
New Hampshire woman one five hundred
fifty nine point seven million dollar
Powerball jackpot last month and
refusing to claim my prize because she
was assumed anonymously and she may be
and she may be having a compelling
reason to seek the guarantee and she
gave me H she gave me twenty grand I'll
go get that money for okay I wish
somebody would ever give my twenty I'll
take the ticket in where did the [ __ ]
like there it turns out we opened up it
turns out winning a jackpot the millions
of dollars even thousands of dollars can
lead to a financial ruin even that
simple recent lottery wonders have
turned up dead in 30 million in
Florida's lottery in 2009 was found
buried in a makeshift grave under a
concrete slab less than three years
later I mean his last name started with
Shakespeare already had yeah a woman who
befriended him and offered to help
manage what remained of his winnings
instead murdered him she was sentenced
to life in prison
nobody got the money no I got the 30
million in Ohio
Debra MacDonald was run over and killed
after leaving a bar this is dumb are you
making us so our depressing we got tip
jeweler some wu-tang nellie tip juror
look alive
rat roof and lifts us up my mother gave
me every depressants that I gotta go
driving traffic up it is crazy it's
crazy how it brings like this super
negative energy into your life yeah sure
isn't that interesting
I'm not accepting a dog yeah I'm
declining will you work your ass off man
that's the remedy you know you just work
your ass off for everything you get in
life that's a moment and that's what
when the universe rewards you with
whatever you desire if you look at logic
you would not think he can spit like
that right well I did we had them on the
show here for you looking at Seaview and
he'll [ __ ] you of logic was dope
good good kid smart kid yeah all right I
need the beat I need to sit down and
think about some [ __ ] I need somebody to
make me mad I needed to go in an alter
ego but to just sit right here and I are
throwing the beat and let me say some
[ __ ] that's gonna be dope that everybody
about all that was cold just in case I
was wondering if you wish I gave me the
freestyle I was kind of I was trying to
scream everybody watch have you a thing
you wrap it you got to be ready at any
moment okay we'll go ahead do you have
anything we could check out oh yeah I
got a whole album oh he's serious Terry
our security
oh you guys are mellow - so look up you
have a stage name or just he will do
just look up money where's the call just
type in money in the lifetime around
Woodley wrapped in love and love and and
love whew man damn mushrooms man yeah my
[ __ ] decide between animates were
assessed where there's been eating yams
goddamn let me see that computer man
money in love all right Missy let's go
go go oh oh no just give it
back to me when you find it it seems
really difficult just
dollish here we go be bears you have I
cut a record company yeah long time back
you need to get back in there Chaplin
you got shown a man our camp camp
already
hey we got a crate win let me man to the
music first then then we can decide
let's hear it
we got to open you up on our festival
yeah yeah yeah you come out to the kind
festivals about Theory Theory th e ry ry
alright yes sir don't get me wrong you
ain't got apple music on her no way hold
back you protested he protested Apple I
love a poo on my phone to apples ain't
that crazy how they get us they change a
charger that changes a whole little big
time there's no doubt about that
you gotta get everything new and [ __ ]
now they're making phone I don't even
have the they don't have any earbud
Angelina buy some time because the Apple
conversation to get you some extra time
okay fine listen I beat your ass I got I
got snoop on a remix to the joint hello
yeah hello
where's on original I beat show ass I
love that and you know I get where the
pit - yeah each time yeah I do hi guys
we finished top we did and see if we can
get him on a FaceTime as I try to find
this song where Khalif
I love that you're just giving a
FaceTime this yeah sure I'd be dope if
you dog didn't look like I'm full of
[ __ ]
not like a bill collector yeah
doesn't look real whiz don't wanna [ __ ]
with us [ __ ] up yeah big fan dude hey
he can train - I saw me in the buff my
first song I had to just get right to
the point
oh so brother the same kind Kelly's up
there we did a challenge for you confuse
now a million different different
versions of the [ __ ] are you doing it
all yourself producing and producing
issues a hold it for them yeah I get
with ya a guy gives you the best
producers do you know the best one do
you ever come like a record deal the
company or something on the break of the
right now label I know but it's also in
an apostle
sweet though it's go independent baby
I'm in the pit oh yeah independent you
think this is money but this your baby
you need a UPS label for distribution
marketing or going independent as hell
man people can download that on iTunes
yes that's the way to go archangels
awesome homie burn on their song called
slide we got a whizzo beat show as being
t-dub Oh crazy
we got spiritual songs on there we got
club songs ample songs lot of [ __ ] love
that man
well is there anything you want to throw
out before we wrap this thing up we're
we're down the center guys TW o OD LD
watch three OS T Woodley with three o's
T Woodley with tools don't want to give
up the handle
he will anybody Instagram can tell them
let me get that real quick cuz you ain't
users in same year 2012 is a big joke
follow me any Instagram Twitter I
shouldn't leave my Beck we out here in
these trees
awesome brother hey man thank you so
much man really thank you
another great episode Mike taketh a
paratha
thank you guys so much for watching
listening remember to subscribe to our
YouTube channel hot box and with Mike
Tyson I'm have been Britain I'm Mike
Tyson I'm Chi wood Oh bye
we're out of here yeah I think I was
gonna get that DJ
[Music]
[Music]